my question is what is justice if I kill
someone by recklessness justice demands
that I pay a price for that not because
I wanted to kill them but because I
should have done more to ensure that I
didn't society needs to know that there
are consequences for not paying enough
attention when doing something
potentially dangerous and the families
left behind they need to know that
society cares enough about their loss to
hold those responsible to account if a
19 year old riding a motorcycle is
killed by someone driving on the wrong
side of the road it's just not good
enough to claim diplomatic immunity for
someone who's not even a diplomat
diplomatic immunity is there to prevent
injustice --is where a state sees
diplomats on trumped-up charges it's not
there to create them there is ZERO
diplomatic benefit to ensuring that
families of American diplomats can kill
Brits without consequence and the
coolest needs to be sent back to the UK
to face justice and face the parents
[Music]
okay sir I completely understand and
sympathize with Harry Dom's mum and dad
sharland Tim I understand that they need
to know about what happened that day not
one to know needs to know they will not
be able to move on drew they're very
they're decent people whose lives have
just been torn apart however and don't
savage me for this I want everyone round
the table have to think about this if
this happened to you if you had done
this and you had diplomatic immunity and
you had three children of your own
would you leave those three children to
come back to this country and
potentially go to jail for a number of
years I think very few people would a
night and I'm it's true people should be
accountable for doing wrong you know I
don't know answer khulus I don't know
her but I suspect she's a she's a decent
woman who did a terrible thing
and and for her to come back to this
country means that her own family is
gonna be torn apart I know that doesn't
help Tim and Charlotte I know it doesn't
and it nothing's gonna bring back their
son but there's part of me that
understands that I'm just wondering how
many people out there how many people
watching
this show would actually do the quotes
right thing and come back and put
themselves off to be sent to prison for
the next however many years and leaving
their families so just wonder I hear
what you're saying but you're talking
from her perspective the idea of she
doesn't want to leave behind her kids
who she cares about more than anything
else I understand that as a concept
however in the criminal justice system
we do not base justice on whether or not
the criminal is willing to face
prosecution alleged criminal exactly and
that is the point of course and you know
the thing is you know that originally
the the diplomatic immunity laws were
intended to prevent embassy staff being
Harris or working in hostile countries
and but but in it is a law that has been
abused we know in this country people
who've been people have escaped
prosecute people have been accused of
rape people have been accused of human
trafficking people have been accused of
drunk driving there are hundreds of
thousands of parking tickets that they
don't pay and and yes if you're if
you're living in a foreign land you
should follow the laws of that land all
I'm saying to you is yeah there's a part
of me that understands and watching
sympathizers with an circle because the
party understands why she has has run
away that's literally what she's done to
protect us Matic immunity doesn't just
apply to the tip Knight applies to their
families so literally within the law
she's operating within the law however I
think her position is indefensible I
think as a mum because she's a man
parent she should never fled the country
she talked to the police she gave no
indication she was going to leave the
country
she's bolted she's a fugitive from
justice so we assume she must be get and
you know and I don't think this is a
banana republic the chances are there
wouldn't have been a custodial sentence
anyway let me just ask Rachel the
question you've got kids what would
would you be conflicted about this I
didn't know that her position was I
can't leave my children and I'm now in
the US and I did think that's a valid
defense I think that she's the only
cover she has is the one she's using and
the one that the US State Department is
maintaining which lets just hear for
what the US State Department is saying
about the mother who managed to kill by
accident or allegedly a 19 year old
any questions regarding a waiver of
immunity with regard to our diplomats in
there
members overseas in a case like this
receives us intense attention at senior
levels and are considered carefully
given the global impact such decisions
carry immunity is rarely waived that's
the US State Department doesn't come
back you know you said just to clarify
that wasn't Kunis's position I will you
then attributed that position to her no
I didn't I just said I said imagine this
imagine what would you do but it's
definitely not a position I think you're
wrong on the law I think you're if if
she did what it's suggested she did she
turn what she went down alongside of the
loads her glasses which we've all done
in our time jealousies but she dug them
in and had that there was an action and
somebody died I think she probably what
good is you well I think it's possible
that when Carol mentioned the parking
tickets there is the sense that if you
are over here with diplomatic immunity
what you're like you can have had your
sort of license to behave and there is
that problem on which it may be this
case should be should be the time where
we resettle didn't he he camped in the
Ecuadorian Embassy for seven years
does anyone think she's gonna come back
no no what a nice thing if the special
relationship counts for anything Boris
should get on the phone to his mate
Donald Trump to say let's look at what
let's look at the human cost here let's
listen to what Harry Dunn's mother
Charlotte Charles's we're just utterly
shocked and appalled that somebody is
allowed to get on a plane and go home
and avoid our justice system you're
handling this with such grace and
dignity and bravery and what you want
from answer Kunis is answers not
necessarily not necessarily punishment
not necessarily punishment at all we
just don't understand from one human to
another and one mom to another how you
could just get on a plane and leave
behind the devastation that she has
without even speaking to us or facing
or an apology of any kind you hear that
you know and your heart breaks I mean
her life is broken it may never ever be
fixed and and and yes the sensible part
of me says she should come back but you
know she says not necessarily punishment
you know maybe if but she can't dictate
that suddenly it would be the police who
decide if that but maybe I I just have
this thing of my head that maybe the two
of them should meet somewhere I don't
know on neutral ground where they can
talk that if that is what that's what
they're asking for and this morning
Donald Trump was speaking about this
issue and he did sort of hint towards
the idea of setting up something like
that but at the same time he also said
in relation to driving on the wrong side
of the road it happens but family we
just said it does it's not a deliberate
thing none of us who've done it did it
deliberately you don't set out to drive
out on the wrong side of the road but it
was an accident the law now see if you
kill something in an accident you are
and you are at fault you are likely to
go to jail in this country that suddenly
changed the law in recent years and I'm
not at all sure that makes sense
personally well nothing would be served
by sending and cyclists to juries I sort
of agree with that I mean you'd be much
better to give a community service or
something I mean this woman is both will
be torn asunder with what that's done
she will but not to something up the
face to face the music let me bring my
shirt because we've got a dad let me
bring that at one point the American
Embassy said that one of them think we
need to consider the global implications
of what a serious sentence would do what
kind of global implications would have
if we set a precedent whereby American
citizens can kill Brits without
consequence that would be incredibly
dangerous and diplomats are given
complete licence by allowing this to go
without any consequence at all no
meeting no nose no community service or
nothing that was at a horrible precedent